hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I I'm just checking in on you I'm taking
time out of my day to read advertising
to make a little more scratch just to
make sure that your week is going okay
all right that's all I'm trying to do
here Jesus Christ I've I hear one more
[ __ ] [ __ ] bring up that stupid
Michael Jackson video I don't what are
they gonna dig them up and arrest them
[Laughter]
you know and I love what anybody did you
see that thing on murder Mountain
did you see the making of a murderer and
you go in there and you listen you
basically you are watching you're
watching the prosecution's case that's
not how a case works then you hear the
defense all right and I think it's kind
of [ __ ] up that you can have something
come out about a dead guy and then
everybody's just gonna be like alright
now we know definitively that this guy D
should be allowed to refute moonwalk out
of the grave and be like listen just
because I talk like this and I like
castles and have a giant ice-cream
machine in like 17 doors that lock on
the way to my bedroom doesn't be even a
[ __ ] a child he should be able to say
that not because I think he's innocent
hey it's it's for you and me right so we
get the chance to do that so someday you
know somebody can't just say hey I saw
this guy with this tallywacker [ __ ]
wagon out of a zipper there right you
have a chance to defend yourself with
this new [ __ ] [ __ ] of the
internet where they just all due process
is thrown out the [ __ ] window the
amount of people that I've seen accused
of this me to [ __ ] and then people just
immediately go like I always knew he was
a piece of [ __ ] it's just like you
haven't heard if you've heard an
accusation but having said that having
said that it makes me feel better about
the suffering of humanity right because
when you look at human being suffering
if you're any sort of a human being it
bothers you alright but when you see 90%
of them on the internet going like oh
you
at that point you like well maybe a baby
maybe they don't need that much food oh
that was just me bill that was to meet
for the morning I I hit him a little bit
of a disappointing morning I was gonna
go fly a helicopter and we couldn't get
the [ __ ] thing started this r22 I
don't know what the deal is like if you
try to start it before 8:00 the
Magneto's are too cold it's too cold
outside this time of year it just
doesn't want to start
so we've we brought a car out to jump it
which we've done before and it's been
fine it looks funny as hell but if you
just don't look at the fact that it's a
car and it's a helicopter and you just
look at the engine you're like oh it's
the same [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] gas
combustion engine all right
same [ __ ] principles here I was
really looking forward to flying and I
know what a lot of you guys are saying
you're like oh my god there's no [ __ ]
way I want two floats out that I had if
I could use that I know I know what
you'll get in your car that [ __ ]
every time you drive a whole puddle at
[ __ ] jizz in your face right coming
up through the rusted out floorboards as
you're texting driving 90 miles an hour
right down the [ __ ] Street we'll say
50 driving 50 looking down at your
[ __ ] phone and there's no guardrail
in this somebody driving 50 miles an
hour just one couple not even like three
feet OPM you have a notice that when you
drive down the [ __ ] Street just on a
two-way street like the fact that you're
going 50 and the other guy's going 50
and it never dawns on you like what if
that guy just [ __ ] swerved over we'd
both be [ __ ] dead it's like you're
doing like what the Blue Angels fly at
each other the last second they turn
away you're doing that with complete
strangers you're not on the radio
talking to each other and every day
every day somebody's on their [ __ ]
phone they drift over headlight to front
headlight BAM right brain smashing on
the inside of the skull and what do
people say what do people say huh oh my
god it's a [ __ ] shape that's it but
the next time you go to get in the car
nobody says like hey maybe you should
walk you're gonna [ __ ] die
so I'm trying to preempt ooh everybody
who's gonna sit there in for [ __ ] say
a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] here anyways
plowing ahead guess who finally figured
out how the MotoGP website works not
this guy
somebody gave me the linkage showed me
and then I was able to
my password and so thank you to the to
the listener who helped me out and I got
to watch that race the first one of the
year in Qatar or what are they called
Kate are the English guys like every
little [ __ ] word they say different
than us it's amazing that we speak the
same language
over here we say ducati they see Ducati
oregano Oregon Oh tomato tomahto Qatar
Qatar I didn't have the scene
I think Qatar Qatar is I think how they
was saying it I don't know when I just
hear [ __ ] like that I really understood
to understand how difficult it is to be
a spy because that's that's the [ __ ]
that gets you caught you get the accent
down you know you watch your little
peaky blinders and you go over there and
next thing you know you're in Buckingham
Palace and you [ __ ] snooping around
to find out what those balding [ __ ] are
doing in there with all the goddamn
money right and then all of a sudden
what do you do you let it Duke it you go
to a Duke Ducati forgot how I said it a
Ducati slip then that's it right the
Queen pushes a button you go through the
floor right down to the Royal alligators
let me tell you right now about MotoGP
this is the best [ __ ] racing that is
out there
alright on the final lap the two the two
people andres de viseo so and Marc
Marquez in first and second place they
changed leads the blade changed three
times in the final [ __ ] lap even
though I knew what happened I was still
up off the couch and everybody was
asleep so they screaming quietly
watching it an amazing race a little bit
of controversy though huh Duke at ease
the Ducatis they got this new little
piece that they have underneath the bike
that allegedly is kicking up air to cool
off the rear tire and these guys I guess
they chew up their tires big time
so if he has this little bit of an
advantage so Davitt CEO so one Ducati
one the team and immediately
four teams complained which I'm guessing
is Honda Suzuki
by the way there's no Harley's or
[ __ ] Indians in the goddamn race what
happened my country we started making
[ __ ] motorcycles before all of these
[ __ ] didn't we I gotta look this up
it's so funny that like Indians in like
Honda's are just feel like fat [ __ ] not
Honda's Harley's essentially it's for
old guys want to sit down I like the
pegs up nice and high so my [ __ ] air
up my old [ __ ] ball bag as I Drive
down the [ __ ] Street and all the
Japanese bikes and the Italian bikes
they're all for the young guys who think
they're gonna live forever right having
said all this having talked all this
[ __ ] you know if I was going to get a
bike which I would love to if I wasn't
you know living for somebody else now
but even then even before I had a kid
like I always like my legs I like my
feet pointing in the direction they're
supposed to be rather than turned around
like I'm [ __ ] like Daffy duck's bill
every other cartoon all right what the
hell was I looking up Oh first
motorcycle built all right let's see who
built it first oh I got the bad Internet
huh sometimes you get the bad cocaine
sometimes you get the bad Internet what
the [ __ ] you doing here can I was first
[ __ ] motorcycle ever built just gonna
bring a point off as I said [ __ ] in
it come on come on you can load you can
you can load if you want to you can
answer my [ __ ] question what is the
jesus [ __ ] christ how much do you
have to pay how much i am [ __ ] paying
nine grand a month for [ __ ] art the
first motorcycle international
combustion petroleum field motorcycle
was was the damn ear right loggin that
sounds like german it was designed and
built by the german inventors
ah you [ __ ] sons up is there anything
worse than when you think a man did
something or America did it and you find
out they didn't it's the worst I feel
like the world smiles when that happens
a motorcycle often called a bike or a
motorbike or a cycle I know what that is
okay
1894 Hildebrand and Wolff Muller became
the first series production motorcycles
and the first to be called a motorcycle
in 2014 the three top motorcycle
produces globally by volume or Honda
Yamaha and the Hero MotoCorp
I don't know it's in India all right so
we're not the only ones making
motorcycles that aren't in MotoGP what
is it about like Italians in Japanese
motorcycles that they just make the
fastest ones they got they got that
unlocked down look at [ __ ] Japan they
got Honda Suzuki and Yamaha so what I'm
finding out is the Suzuki's of the best
in the corners but then the Ducatis in
Honda's just have too many horses when
they go down the straightaway which is
[ __ ] weird to me you know I guess it
would depend on the track cuz the one
they were riding though riding on had
like two long straightaways so any sort
of [ __ ] ground the dude in the Suzuki
would gain he would just lose it every
time you would go by the grandstands
over there all right enough motorcycle
talk but I really enjoyed it if you want
to jump on board there's only like 20
[ __ ] races they're like 22 23 24 laps
they fly by and you're watching guys
going two hundred [ __ ] miles an hour
on a motorcycle like an eighth of an
inch away from each other
son I'll tell you I've been given Yanis
Pappas [ __ ] one of my favorite comics
out there absolutely brilliant guy but
he's like the classic [ __ ] new yorker
where he did this Instagram post right
and he's like in Philadelphia and he
goes look at these DS going look at the
buildings look at the buildings look at
the buildings and he goes every city
looks like new New York City for a block
and a half and then the whole thing
falls apart you know and I guess there's
something just so [ __ ] funny about the
way
New Yorkers travel you know every place
they go to if they can't do exactly what
the [ __ ] they can do in New York City
the place sucks it's like you're in
Philadelphia why would it look like New
York City that's why you travel the
tri-state area is arguably the biggest
collection of meatheads
in the United States of America and I
and this is saying something because I
grew up in Greater Boston you know and
if you want to see the level of meathead
just watch a Boston sporting event when
they pay into the crowd all right and
I'm not talking down I know I'm part of
the problem so I've just been leaving
all these [ __ ] messages how New
Yorkers just think everything sucks
there's such [ __ ] [ __ ] oh I went to
[ __ ] Houston right I'm in Houston
Texas so I ordered linguine and it
[ __ ] it was really [ __ ] terrible
can't get good Italian in Houston Texas
why didn't you get the barbecue you dumb
[ __ ] why don't you get some Tex Mex I
don't was [ __ ] I went to Buffalo
right I [ __ ] went to the Buffalo Wild
Wings if [ __ ] wings aren't that good
[ __ ] morons they are [ __ ] morons
so you know what's funny I um I went to
the Brody memorial right I came off I
talked about this on Monday I still
can't get over this this guy was
eulogizing is that the right word Brody
Stevens and he somehow was able to trash
Boston twice he [ __ ] eulogy it was
one of the high points of it because it
was you know it was really uplifting but
it was sad but it was kind of funny to
see that New York fans are that [ __ ]
annoyed that we want some championships
finally you know finally won a couple
you know and that it's bothering them so
much that they're now reduced to making
fun of our skyline and that stupid [ __ ]
that ESPN came up with where they were
like saying that Boston had an
inferiority complex
is one of my favorite with New York is
one of my favorite thing ever I don't
have the heart to tell in New York is
that like yeah we don't even we didn't
even know whether we didn't know what
the [ __ ] it looked like you giving us
too much credit I want to say I already
talked about this on Monday but you know
like whenever they [ __ ] show
New England whenever there's a game in
New England they're always showing some
sort of foliage something about the
Revolutionary War and then somebody's
eating a [ __ ] oyster or something
it's just like that's really that's
that's not a good that's not a good
indication of what's going on up here
[Laughter]
you know so somebody in a dive bar with
a beer and a [ __ ] shot then yeah
maybe and then don't then don't go to
the bull and Finch that stupid [ __ ]
cheers thing or whatever the hell it is
anyways
having said that to all the New Yorkers
listening I absolutely love your city I
love the people I just don't like the
Yankees that's it everything else about
it I absolutely love having said that I
love Philadelphia too I enjoy Washington
DC Milwaukee is one of my favorite
cities I don't [ __ ] because when I go
there I don't try to get [ __ ] don't
let's get some [ __ ] kill the [ __ ]
clam chowder sucked in Green Bay go dude
I [ __ ] in I go to I go to [ __ ]
Argentina right dude I'm [ __ ] down
there and I say to the guy can I get a
[ __ ] Sam Adams think I didn't even
have to see he had no Sam Adams so I
told this [ __ ] place sucks
do you anybody else do you have any
stories like that I shouldn't really
just blame New Yorkers but does anybody
else have like because I think country
people are like that too where they just
kind of look to vinay now y'all deal
with this all these [ __ ] faithful out
here man give give me the wide open
spaces in my own property
get me a four-wheeler and a good woman
who doesn't have the self-esteem to walk
off right she knows I'll [ __ ] Club
her over the head and feed her to my
pigs I've done it before
she
knows it we never talked about it but
she knows that she goes out when she
goes to feed the pig she sees a couple
of thongs hanging on a nail she knows
what that means I told her I've been
married twice before she gets it yeah
people the purpose of traveling is is is
the when in Rome right what in Rome do
as the Romans do that's what you do all
right you [ __ ] go over there you go
over the [ __ ] you know the UK right
Premier League see get yourself a
[ __ ] pint in a scarf and start
singing some songs all right you know
pull over see like an in Saudi and you
talk to some 90 year old woman over
there you know in blazing fast English
going like hey do you know what we can
watch the NFL divisional round playoffs
you know what it is I think about New
Yorkers they've just they've just sung
too many [ __ ] songs about your city
and then all these meatheads who really
didn't do that well in schools they
think they're part of the success rather
than the just background in the movie as
I've always said Frank Sinatra was
bridge-and-tunnel
he was a Jersey guy franksen he lives in
no work there's no buildings that
[ __ ] place sucks
all right plowing ahead here I did some
stand-up the other night first time
since Royal Albert Hall I had a good
time trying out new [ __ ] just like just
nothing
I got nothing so I'm gonna go down to
the comedy store possibly this weekend
well maybe not this week I mean me next
weekend and I'm just gonna [ __ ] I'm
just gonna do 20 minutes of new [ __ ] I'm
just gonna have like four five six
subjects written down and I'm going
onstage and I'm just gonna stand there
and [ __ ] take it and it's one of my
favorite things in the world to do I was
just listening to Brody special the one
that he has on [ __ ] iTunes and I just
don't know just listening to that guy
plowing through it's just one of my
favorite things definitely gonna miss
that guy
but it was an incredible memorial
service which I really would think
I talked about it on Monday I believe I
did I just kept no [ __ ] short-term
memory so anyways a nose funny was right
before I started I asked my wife if she
could just go talk in the other room
because she was talking she had a phone
on speaker and you know I was recording
just didn't want that [ __ ] in the
background oh my god the [ __ ] look
she gave me it's unbeliev
like she's asking me to do [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] time can you go here can you
pick up this can you do this can you do
that I lasted it we just moved down one
room close the door she just looked me
cuz I know what she's gonna say you
[ __ ] talk so [ __ ] loud when you
man the [ __ ] phone
get the cat the cook at the guilt yeah
you know it's always always comes back
always come back Haeju Rosa sent me some
I guess they got this new [ __ ]
Charlie Manson movie that's coming out
whether they're trying to make the women
that Charlie convinced to kill those
people victims I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're a victim or not if you're dumb
enough that you let some [ __ ] psycho
look in Jesus talk to you into murdering
a pregnant woman and then trying to cut
the baby out yet you shouldn't be
walking around in society this is the
new [ __ ] thing the new [ __ ] thing
now is to go back in time and find a
bunch of selfish [ __ ] and then somehow
blame it on guys and you know what it
started with it started with that stupid
movie monster
well that [ __ ] lunatic was a serial
killer and I'm watching the movie and
they're trying to make me feel guilty
like I'm part of the problem I'm the
reason why she became one I saw the
Jeffrey Dahmer movie they didn't do that
they just like this guy's out of his
[ __ ] mind and he's eating people but
it's a woman there has to be a reason
maybe she just came out of the womb a
complete [ __ ] psycho right maybe
that's what it was I don't [ __ ] know
I think they tried to like find some
sort of trajectory in the madness of
Jeffrey Dahmer but at no point did they
blame women although in fairness to the
they who's that guy Ed Gein guy the guy
from [ __ ] Wisconsin they did try to
they did say that his mother [ __ ] him
up so I don't know maybe I'm just being
a baby you know maybe I should have
moved to uh one room over is that is
that what I should have done alright so
as I mentioned the Bruins lost two in a
row two in a row hoping to get back on
track here I'm going to the [ __ ]
gadna dreams April 2nd everybody April
2nd I'm doing the garden of dreams with
Jon Stewart this is in New York City by
the way oh my god the arena is
unbelievable it's so much nicer than
arenas another [ __ ] [ __ ] cities I'm
doing it's Jerry Seinfeld Jon Stewart
Elijah Schlesinger
who else who else who else I forget who
else those are the names that I remember
oh and yours truly how could I forget
lovely make lovely ball did not even
balding bald me that's the name of my
one show one-man show lovely bald me
I've chosen me I've decided to ignore
all the advertising that's saying that
I'm not good enough and to say that I am
good enough how fragile is your [ __ ]
psyche that you [ __ ] sit there
looking at advertising and it [ __ ] with
you to that level that you're walking
out behind a [ __ ] Papa John's
throwing up into a handicap parking spot
right and I know what you think could
bill why would you suggest that Papa
John's puts the handicap parking behind
I've never eaten at Papa John's alright
I like Papa Gino's nice [ __ ] Italian
I don't want some guy named John making
my goddamn pizza alright I want someone
to get a [ __ ] tan not someone who
burns in [ __ ] April um what was I
talking about I just yeah I mean what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you first of all
the arrogance of you that you look at a
Victoria's Secret model and you feel
like you have to compete with that first
of all you can't any more than I can
compete with a Brad Pitt so what is the
[ __ ] problem
and the second of all wasn't last time
you saw a Victoria's Secret model
walking to the bar that you're drinking
that all right you [ __ ] regular look
in person you're in a regular looking
person bar you know with me and the
second and eight walks in the room
everybody [ __ ] turns like like bo
Derek just came walking in and that
movie ten Hollywood just creates these
impossible standards yes it's a movie I
[Laughter]
don't understand like I like when they
do this reboot a Top Gun I'm not gonna
feel like I need to learn how to fly
[ __ ] f18 to wherever the [ __ ] they're
flying was it f19 up the up to the
nineteen what are they up to now let's
see us a top fighter jet all right what
do we got here
don't even [ __ ] tell me it's called
this the sukhoi su-15 lou is it made in
japan do we make anything here please
tell me an Asian American came up with
that and they they make this in Indiana
please for the love of God do you guys
how [ __ ] up that was if all our
fighter jets are made in Japan and then
we have beef with them again and it's
like hey man can you keep make it making
us jets so like we can get you back for
bombing the other part of Hawaii now top
ten best fighter jets in the world the
top seven u.s. fighter jets how come
they're not they're not doing the the
eff anymore the JT f-22 dude I'm so old
I remember I remember the F 60 the f16
was the bomb and I remember a 240z
before the 280z before the 300 all right
I remember the f100 I don't who's the
f-150 and f250 I just needed another
example was another one where they just
kept going up the Mazda rx-7 what are
they up to nine I love I think they just
they don't start it won like Jordans
like the sneakers you know then there
was a Jordan - Jordan threes they
started like seven or a hundred if you
wonder what the [ __ ] I'm talking about I
don't know either
alright I have no idea but anyways I'm
doing the guy
no dreams on April 2nd it's in the it's
the theater at Madison Square Garden as
I mentioned on Monday this is where
Eddie Murphy did the raw special so I
always think about that so I will be
there and I'm also the day before I'm
gonna go try to go to a Brooklyn Nets
game now I haven't gone to a pro game in
a minute
as far as checking another one off the
list and I had forgotten I only need
like six more teams and I've been to a
home game of every pro team in all four
[ __ ] sports now there's a very select
few of you that thinks that's awesome
and that's what I'm talking to right now
the rest of you could just [ __ ] zone
out cuz this part of the podcast it's
it's not about you anymore
then an average looking woman has to
feel intimidated because you know
there's another Cindy Crawford coming
along her daughters now gonna make a
whole other generation of people not
feel pretty enough and I got to tell you
something there there is a beauty in
coming to the realization that you you
aren't pretty enough and just embracing
that just being like you know what I'm
gonna be the coolest six that walks into
this bar tonight
it's all right being a six then just add
add to it you know tell a couple of
jokes learn how to juggle you know what
I mean it's like you ever see somebody
when they get a three Chrysler 300 and
they try they try to make it look like a
Bentley that's what you do but at no
point do you actually say that you're a
[ __ ] Bentley or do you get mad that
somebody's making a Bentley so any of
that makes sense I don't [ __ ] this is
usually a point here where I would read
some advertisement but I didn't get any
so far I wonder why probably cuz I [ __ ]
on every goddamn one of them you know
and they [ __ ] sensitive I think these
women todayy a [ __ ] sets it if you
think these Millennials get their
feelings hurt see these [ __ ]
advertising companies can't see a
goddamn thing oh I do ever read here we
go darling club dude has everything you
need to look feel and smell your best
and you never have to go to us still
that's because they delivered everything
you need right to your front door you
lazy bastard and they keep you fully
stocked on what you what you you see you
don't run out here's how it works Dollar
Shave Club has everything you need to
get ready they have you covered from
head to toe for your hair your skin your
face you name it they got a deodorant
for your taint they have this new
program where they automatically keep
you stocked up on products you use you
determine what you want when you want it
and shows right up your door from once a
month to once every six months so ever
you want to do it plus they're handsome
discount the more you buy the more you
save and right now though a shave club
has a bunch of status sets you can try
for just five bucks like their oral care
kit ladies after they the restock box
ships regular size products at regular
price get your status set for just five
dollars right now at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / / so so
here we are and it's now time to talk
about soccer
I guess Liverpool my adopted team is
still down a point to those Man City
[ __ ] alright what their uh way they get
their money from somebody told me god
damn it it's not Saudi Arabia is it you
know do they get it from air Emirates
does anybody get it from the airline
throw some of their first-class [ __ ]
ticket money at them I don't remember
anyways they're down a point they're
down a point they got a game Liverpool's
got a game on Monday they pay for Fulham
as I would say so they're probably full
amp Fulham on st. Paddy's day uh st.
Paddy's day you got to get out there
where your green plastic at you know
where's my hash tag on that day where I
get a fed - Debra's going on a green
alligator the lone neck goose everyone's
getting [ __ ] you don't realize how
[ __ ] up that is you know how funny it
is Irish people or part Irish people
they go out and they just like there's
no other [ __ ] holiday you know where
people go out in
in people who are our that nationality
literally go out and do the the most
like negative stereotype of themselves
you know Black History Month everybody's
on their best behavior right Jewish
holidays everybody's [ __ ] chillin st.
Patty's Day what happens hi everybody
goes out gets drunk in the [ __ ]
Street dresses like a leprechaun and
passes out in the gutter that's what
happens right [ __ ] corned beef
sandwich [ __ ] hanging out of the side
of your mouth that's what I always hate
about that holiday it's like like one of
the prides of the Irish is not only do
you drink you can handle your [ __ ]
liquor don't but don't can you guys just
don't just don't make a mess of yourself
[ __ ] sitting there drinking green beer
the [ __ ] you're doing oh [ __ ]
Odell Beckham jr. goes from the Giants
to the Cleveland Browns Cleveland Brown
fans beside themselves can't believe
their good fortune
now they got they got that kid there
what's-his-face there they got the
quarterback I just based on his name
Baker Mayfield right he's got a little
bit of a swagger
he likes talking a little bit of [ __ ]
right he likes doing something and doing
a little dance in front of the [ __ ]
crowd now he's got a wide receiver right
so what's good this might work if they
have like an Al Davis old-school sort of
thing because this reminds me of what
the Raiders used to do where they would
take the [ __ ] people everybody said
don't take or the outcasts of other
teams and then they would go in there
and everybody would just be themselves
and they would have a good time I hope
it works out for the Browns my gut says
I can't say that it won't it just all
depends on the coach the personality
like that's a good Rex Ryan team because
then he's talking shed Odell's talking
shed Baker's doing what the [ __ ] he does
but it's definitely gonna be exciting
but I actually think I think it was a
good move for for the Giants
he didn't kind of fit into there they
have vibe defensive-minded organization
you look at Eli shows up he's got khakis
on he tucks his shirt in I mean
that'sthat's what the Giants I guess
have become I don't know you listen to
some of those LT stories oh they'll fit
right in but I don't know it was a big
move and I don't I don't think they had
to give all give up too much for the guy
and they got a lot of draft picks so
we'll see what they do and I've got a
couple friends of mine that have
Cleveland Brown fans and they're all
saying that GM knows what he's doing so
who knows the only thing I need out of
Cleveland plans is to stop calling your
stupid city the land the land Oh [ __ ]
Midwest people the land the burg do they
call Cincinnati the natty get on the bus
you're in Columbus you get it the day
welcome to the day so what they say in
Dayton all right sorry I'm being a [ __ ]
but it's what I do
all right that's it I'm gonna be out and
about in LA doing some spots bombing
this weekend probably down the store on
Friday that's the deal
all right so go Bruins go Celtics
baseball is starting up interesting stat
here and this is something the only
success of the New York Yankees do you
realize the New York Yankees are so
[ __ ] successful that since they got
Babe Ruth alright from the 1920s to this
decade they've only gone one decade
where they didn't win a war at least one
World Series and that was the 1980s and
even still they went to a World Series
in 81 and lost right if they don't win
this year this will be the first time
that that's the only second time this
has happened since women were allowed to
vote okay which was another huge
huge [ __ ] mistake by this country
okay you should have kept those [ __ ]
broads in the kitchen no I think it's
great that they could talk more anyways
am I the only one who's like not looking
forward to this next election
presidential election I just I just
don't see this I just see it being a
repeat of a few years ago and it's just
gonna be a [ __ ] train wreck until you
get that cancer out of the locker room I
just don't know what it's gonna be if I
you know if I was running for president
on the Democratic side what I would
learn how to do is talk some [ __ ] all
right
stop trying to talk about issues what
you need to do is you need to go in
there you need to make fun of his hair
make fun of that toupee make fun of his
[ __ ] big motherly hips you got it you
got to go after him like that
all right why is why is your face orange
and underneath your eyes his ghost white
do you have a tanning bed is that some
sort of cream that you put under your
eyes for puffiness that's what you do do
not go up there and try to talk policy
and interrupt the [ __ ] out of them just
do what he does completely ignore all
the [ __ ] rules and then when you get
called on it just act like a victim all
right that's what it's gonna be this is
what politics is [ __ ] become I mean
I'm acting like it was on the up-and-up
before that but uh I don't know we shall
see although I do have to give Trump's
and props grounding that that airplane
right he did do that he did try to pull
the troops out of Syria you saw the
Democrats and Republican
you biting the hand that feeds white net
corporate cash all spilling out of their
pockets and you watch all you ladies out
there loving your girl there
the 29 year old check you watch you [ __ ]
it well how sue before she gets a book
deal how sue before she somehow a
multi-millionaire only making 150 200
grand a year but she has a vagina so so
do you so
should vote for right that should make
you feel good all right that was a Conte
way to end but that's how it's gonna
happen enjoy the music and there will be
another half-hour of greatest hits from
a Thursday afternoon just before Monday
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast from earlier this year or years
before I Anna I don't [ __ ] alright
have a great weekend you [ __ ] go
Liverpool I'll see you on Monday
[Music]
five Canadian street light step aside of
the shades you and me babe Julian says
nearly give me a heart attack
he's underneath the window she's
[Music]
you know I'm not showing that Naomi
Campbell she's like 52 is she's still
have sexy so it's like Tyra got a lot of
years to go Dec know who did we see
walking away from that hotel that day
Oh Cheryl Tiegs Cheryl Tiegs looking
good that time is not [ __ ] man you
really time is a [ __ ] no honest I
realize the judgmental mom forgot hi
dude I'm working my this one metal and I
think you got a bit of a fetish known
you for a while and older white women
and he took some bad what Hillary
Clinton I my favorite all white one do
it number one is a Carly Simon I will
still popular Simon I don't know why I
don't know why everybody got their
[ __ ] fetishes album cover alone well
she was on all fours well that big mouth
yeah that's what st. John the Brockman
met [ __ ] by the way a lot of people
backed us up on that one oh yeah Bakula
Cornell say for the profit so how are
you every pop-up what a lazy but we saw
in a mom moving back though we saw
Cheryl Tiegs leaving the Donald Trump
roast yeah Cheryl Tiegs we had the great
seats from Voss well yeah barely in the
building thanks Richie but I got two
tickets for the Trump row section oh
it's gonna be great you know where we
were assured in the upper we were behind
a monitor that was showing the rows
behind it on the second floor dude
everyone's going in the main ballroom
and we handed our tickets like yeah
we're gonna be hobnobbing with the the
top celebrities in New York right
also the usher looks at our tickets and
goes oh god take that elevator
oscillator but the and then you're
thinking alright well you know it's an
elevator
you ever see a roast with is an upstairs
it's always it's the the dais and the
taillights so we're like upstairs at our
roast so it first like alright well
we'll follow all the other people that
have seats in that area no there were
maybe another 20 people that had
seattle-area let me sit down and then I
have my seat stunk I had to stand up and
look over this video screen to see
anything
I couldn't tell who was up at the the
favorite time Jay is everybody going the
elevators like holding cable and [ __ ]
yeah that's what it was they're all tech
guys
gaffers they are heading for the [ __ ]
mixing board
so heading for the walkways high above
and so we leave the roasts were walking
back toward the station and we're right
behind Cheryl Tiegs and her white old
saggy ass like how bad that looked at
Emily's dad tears and I'm saying for an
old old lady she probably isn't that bad
but when you compare her to the Cheryl
Tiegs poster that was on everybody's
wall with the netting that she was just
wearing a net and her nipples were
poking through I mean you wouldn't [ __ ]
Saffy Loren no just cause she exists 60
something Lauren got a Papa do-si-do I
don't there's got to be a just a glimpse
of just young Sofia swatch job half a
[ __ ] lip painting out there yeah
believe me and when you see these people
out remember they are looking their
absolute best all right this is the best
they can possibly look how old is Cheryl
Tiegs 50 gotta bake she's gonna be all
inner inner 55 and she's gonna fit is a
no redeeming sexuality she not drive I
didn't see any redeeming sexuality I saw
an older woman that you look at and go
alright she's you know an older woman
that doesn't look like she's ready to
fall apart what do you you know the old
broad women like who continued to dye
the hair like that love it because like
a [ __ ] birds nests it's all dried out
Ryan Burnett also like her she says get
into likey you get into like your 60s
it's like the smell of rotten of your
pending death so you start having that
old person smell so when you see the top
of the head what is in advance I guess
of what you told me to see right through
that
any hair it's like [ __ ] white cotton
candy hair and you can golf price rate
is it'll old age but back to the back of
her hand she's jerking you want you got
it you got a [ __ ] old Sofia Lorraine
[ __ ] movie on the TV try not to look
at the what happened that'll run way way
Cheryl don't you got that Cup oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] close your eyes Sofia
close your eyes it's so an opened up Ark
of the Covenant in front of that [ __ ]
right on man no she she looks like you
know a nice older lady but you know you
haven't you're just against you're just
against old [ __ ] I can feel wait you
know what I disagree with it it it's not
I I went when I wanted that it's because
the Heinz ol [ __ ] because he's
comparing it to the memory had yeah what
it is hot I'm remembering what she
looked like
Oh who's the hottest old that you know
that's a question obviously knew her was
because she was a sex symbol so already
there is an old [ __ ] I know and and and
his is the criteria Zion Sawyer
it's not one that became that used to be
hot too part and just maintained it but
like oh she used wait she shoots to be
super hot but now she's all [ __ ] like
Cheryl Tiegs but she's still like you
know I'll kill Elsa was up good god
knows i mean now [ __ ] now back
then not when she was old and eighty
remember baby
Howard Hawk was still young goofy makeup
yeah I'm done i right this second she's
a bad [ __ ]
god damn at least what's the what's old
enough are all you guys do is he'll go
back to the seventies and think who do
who did I want to [ __ ] back then I was
trying to think but they were all I
never wanted to put my mom's back then
whatever a hot-looking an old [ __ ] that
you would old AG right now Pam Grier Pam
Grier nah
who Jessica Simpson was all
outside 22 years oldi I took the bid and
went the other way
I can I think I'm trying I'm going
through like old 70s TV show kind of
things coming up they're coming it's
very in raw so we seem like a filthy
before Marian along but the mother from
happy was old then I like to hear in
Brussels for Village House on the
Prairie the mother from little house
Marion Ross was a bit of a [ __ ] mother
so yeah there's always answer yeah that
is haunted shed something her and Fonzie
going to go now talk about my mom
there's always ants mom shut up
Anthony's mother's heart yeah
never talk about my mom like that I talk
about it she takes care of herself but
you know she's no spring chicken oh
that's nice lovely awkward moment I had
with a good friend of mine the other day
Lee he came to town I took him to a
Knicks game right he's sitting there
right and I go and he's talking about my
little sister he goes well how how old
how old is she now huh and I'm like uh
he goes you seen high school you gotta
go dude you can't believe she's
graduating high school he goes good Lord
will get known like oh yeah I should see
it I'm she knows beautiful girl and he
goes he goes well the apple doesn't fall
too far from the tree your mother was
always really attractive it was just
kind of silent right so used to jerk off
to my mom raised great to know yeah yeah
you gotta fill in the blank and dad that
obviously Ridge yeah oh Linda Carter Pat
Benatar Lynda Carter Lynda Lynda Carter
now Linda Carter now Linda [ __ ] yes
let me say something I wasn't a little
bit harder when James Wonder Woman let
me tell you else that [ __ ] from Buck
Rogers and 24 Aaron gray
she was very hot during that time oh now
god she's still a hot good she's done so
much Suzanne Somers that's the [ __ ]
well but she got that that carbocation
she's really old man let's go to uh Jim
and Waco
Jim she kept this day yeah Lynda Carter
man it that's every time I see her all I
think about is it slow motion I hated
those [ __ ] big bloomer
panty things she wore we made it look
like she had like I wanna be walking
around with those now Victoria's Secrets
by now that big bloom a [ __ ] with those
fake boots
what not is never into her even as a kid
like when she was one-to-one Cilicia was
too motherly looking about Lani and too
old
she's just budding I've had hot she's
just she's when I was [ __ ] her when I
was 10 I was into ten-year-old girls
when I was 12 I was into twelve-year-old
girls 14 14 year old girls that's how I
went I was never like 14 into 38 year
old women I never found them attractive
they were like moms so whatever your
name is you're whatever height age was
up until 15 and then it was always just
fifteen-year-old so so fun just did he
just make okay so 14 you weren't into 28
year old now that means though so let's
double it he's not into something double
his age so and he's like eight so how
old was shown got to be a hundred and
twenty-two years old I was trying to
back you into that corner yes please
over I know I'm falling down bo Derek is
coming Oh Derek still hot bo Derek now
okay if you got a point out a hotter
older woman all right I'll give it to bo
Derek still looks good the doesn't look
like she's trying to keep herself young
with [ __ ] surgery and [ __ ] there's
nothing worse than these duck-billed
[ __ ] old broads walking around
creeping which is odd I'm adjusted
lip-syncing it looks good it ladies you
look freakish you look like ducks
it's creepy they talk like wicked could
I please kind of pedicure appointment
for next week one outside oh there's a
creep and I don't like that look it is
awful
through the bars over
[Music]
late everyone will some a man finds that
streetlight steps out of the shade you
and me babe
[Music]
me
you